faut qu'ils aient du travail il faut que
l'intensité faut que ça bosse
sérieusement
effectivement le plaisir il se fait dans
la victoire ok les boys allez on sera à
votre aîné et les boys comme il les
appelle ils sont motivés
ces jeunes viennent de terminer la
saison régulière à une honorable
quatrième place ce qu'il envoie une
qualification pour les play-offs
ils devront maintenant affronter les
meilleures équipes de nationale 1 en
deux matches couperets le noyau est
reconstitué l'équipe et est maintenu et
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire maintenant
ben on est en play offs était s'était
pas spécialement l'objectif
quand et compétitif quand tu es
compétiteur part d'un ça en devient
hélas clairement les gars ont montré que
sur le terrain et dans le groupe il
avait envie de gagner quoi
je pars avec le palais je donne en bas
ok je reste sur ma bande face au jeu si
possible au tableau met au point les
dernières tactiques avec tout juste 20
ans de moyenne d'âge ce groupe est le
plus jeune du championnat très vite
chacun a su trouver sa place
le potentiel semble être là la
motivation aussi
je trouve que l'équipe est vraiment
soudé parce qu'il ya pas mal de nouveaux
et ça aurait pu être plus long à faire
finale il a fallu de trois matchs pour
pouvoir sous d être vraiment vraiment
comme une famille vraiment prêts à se
battre les uns pour les autres
ce que en étant plus jeune la cité le
niveau senior quand même il est haut et
il faut être deux fois plus fort dans la
tête de photophores ensemble et ouais ok
les gars on patine un peu par la premier
match de play-offs samedi soir contre
ris orangis
on joue à domicile l'enjeu est important
ces play-offs permettront peut-être aux
apaches d'accéder à la ligue élite
[Applaudissements]